a few years ago
um we've got apologies from councillor
rita chair
okay thank you
are we any declarations of interest
nope nope item three then
local government miscellaneous
provisions act
1982 draft sex establishments
policy review uh pages 4 to 45.
has everybody been able to have a look
at it yeah
right kevin are we over to you at this
point
thank you very much chair um debbie from
legal was supposed to be coming to do
the report but unfortunately she can't
attend this afternoon so i've agreed
that i'll
take members through the report um
i will try and keep it relatively brief
as you will recall
the committee's already passed a
resolution to adopt the
legislation and that we should go out to
public consultation on a
draft policy that draft policy
has now been prepared and is attached to
the report
it's been before the security committee
scrutiny committee
they're happy with that and um i'd just
like to go through it quickly today
with members and if everybody is happy
with it then
hopefully we can go out to a 12 week
consultation
and then take it forward from there
is that okay with your chair that's fine
carry on
okay so um the the policy itself
covers things uh like introduction to
the policy
citing the findings of the public
consultation which obviously
aren't in there yet because we haven't
done that
um setting out the statutory criteria
in relation to the mandatory and
discretionary grounds for refusal of the
application
separating the detailing of the
council's policy
in respect of the granting of licenses
for each type of sex establishment
being that a sex entertainment venue sex
sentiment or sex shops
detailing the other legislation that's
relevant to any grant or refusal of the
license
specifying exemptions setting out the
application procedure for those
for variations renewals transfers and
revocations
and then detailing the interpretation of
the legislation
and also setting out the standard
conditions um
for each type of sex establishment
should we ever receive any applications
so that those standard conditions can be
attached to the licenses
yeah so i'm happy to take questions or
comments from members at this stage
uh cancer cancer pickering
uh thank you chair just uh just a couple
of um
well bunch of comments and once for
explanation really
in the last section which is about
sex shops i noticed unless i'm
reading it wrong or missing something
there's nothing about
um safety and security in there
there is on the other two when it's uh
quite explicit about cameras and what
they should be like um
etc on the premises there's nothing on
the [ __ ] on the
sex shops ones the last bit
right okay i'm sure that that's
something that we can actually look at
yeah that's that's fine thank you very
much council pickering and you wrote the
euro of the comments
question uh the other ones are just for
um
clarification for my benefit really it
talks about vessels vehicles and stalls
could you just explain what uh
vessels and stalls are i could
understand the vehicles bit i think um
kevin might be able to understand this
obviously vessels
vessels is is issue so or something like
that
um source would be saying market stall
or something of that
i will presume um and obviously
vehicles are you know moving vehicles
so theoretically they can
somebody could have a sex shop that is
either on a vessel a stove
or a vehicle um i'm not sure that it
will comply with our conditions and i'm
not sure that we will
grant the license but there is an option
that there could be an application from
that type of premises
is that okay kevin
i think i'd just add to that i think the
the intention of stall is
to cover any temporary uh pop-up
type um
location or so that would uh
be of a sort of transitory and temporary
nature
uh thank you thank you that explanation
it's just um
it's just i presume it would make it
much more difficult to um
monitor that if somebody applied for um
a stall and they were on car boots or
somewhere else rather
if it's fixed premises it's easier to
monitor i suppose than if it's somewhere
that's portable and
and can move around so it just clarifies
that in my mind thank you very much
thank you thank you
is um cancer right
you you muted still
yes you can hear me now yes yes thank
you
uh i'm referring to item number 54
on page 24.
just bear with me a second and
right yes yes it says suitable and
sufficient training
shall be be provided to all staff and
such training to be documented blah blah
blah
um where would you go
or who would you go to to enable you to
get
training of staff it depends
on what training we're actually looking
at
that may well be training around
security staff working at the premises
it could also be around things like the
sale of alcohol
it could be about checking age
restrictions on people coming through
the door
um so there are training courses out
there i'm not suggesting that the
suitable and sufficient training relates
to the actual
performances or anything like that it's
about the operation and management of
the premises yeah
just there it could be training on how
to use the cctv
correctly install the images correctly
yeah yeah i understand various aspects
of that
that sort of you know yeah okay thank
you thank you
thank you is there anybody else like to
ask anything
no i don't think there is kevin no no
yes so it's over to yourself to to see
whether or not the members want this to
go out to public consultation
are we all happy with that with the um
changes suggested by councillor
pickering being added
to jobs yet yep
yes kevin that's uh that's fine by us
thank you that's that's me doing on that
item then thank you very much chair
thank you uh item four um the taxis
policy has been postponed as it until
january am i right about that
uh yes chair um while whilst it's
uh it's in the pipeline and a lot of
work's been done on it it's not quite
right yet
i'd rather bring you a polished document
and something that's half
uh half done so we we need a bit more
time to work on that and we'll bring it
back in the new year
okay all right thank you well i think
that's probably
us finished then i've got no oh just a
second cancel row
sorry jeff thank you i'm just curious to
know if you're thinking about when we uh
close the public clear cross for coving
beaches of code rules
is that drop in court in december am i
correctly thinking that
uh just for clarification um yes
uh the premises that we took the license
off was
from multiple breaches and that included
some issues around
opening following the coffee lock down
um
that has as part of kovid been adjourned
off several times by the court
this year uh we are currently waiting uh
i believe by the start of next week we
should have been told what date it's
going to be
back in court um once we've got
once we've got some sort of news fear
then of course we'll report back but
as with almost everything at the moment
the court just keeps pumping them
only apologizing i couldn't get in
straight away i was rejected first time
and came in late
that's all right you weren't you weren't
very late thank you could could
could you did uh did apologies go in for
councillor anne holmes
no they didn't well thank you can you
can you people
i mean that was that was my duty today
to first of all apologize for handcuffs
okay thank you
thank you very much thank you
right that's it then thank you very much
everybody okay thank you very much
you